I'm so excited!
It's almost Valentine's Day!
Valentine's Day is celebrated on February 14th.
For many people, it is the most romantic day of the year.
People often give flowers, cards, jewelry, and of course, chocolate.
Couples often go out for a romantic dinner.
In North America, Valentine's Day is celebrated from a very young age.
Children often make homemade Valentine's Day cards.
They use crayons, colored paper, scissors, glue and many other things.
After making the card, they write a personal message on it...
...and then they exchange them with each other.
Children also exchange and eat lots of chocolate.
Hershey's Kisses are especially popular.
Will you be my Valentine?